estamos acostumbrados a pensar en
mercados de bienes y servicios y en
demanda y oferta de bienes y servicios
lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo será
ampliar nuestra percepción de lo que es
un mercado usando el mercado de fondos
prestables ahora este término parece muy
técnico fondos prestables pero
literalmente son fondos que la gente
ofrece para que sean prestados a otra
gente otras personas que están
demandando es decir que quieren pedir
prestado entonces una manera de pensar
en este mercado es los oferentes de este
mercado son los ahorradores así que
cuando ahorras algo de dinero y lo metes
al banco el banco presta ese dinero a
alguien más y como el banco tiene
interés de esa persona puede pagarte
algo de interés a ti como ahorrador no
siempre tiene que ser a través de un
banco pero así sucede comúnmente pueden
existir otros tipos de intermediarios
del mismo modo quienes son los
demandantes o de dónde viene la demanda
bueno la demanda viene de las personas
que quieren un préstamo
para hacer una inversión tal vez hay
algún tipo de negocio disponible para
ellos y como ya lo mencioné este no es
un mercado donde los oferentes y los
demandantes o los ahorradores y los
prestatarios necesariamente interactúen
directamente puede ser que obtengas un
préstamo de tu cuñada o de tus padres
pero muchas veces por lo general no
obtienes de algún tipo de institución
algún tipo de institución financiera
generalmente bancos donde los
ahorradores ponen su dinero no solo para
tenerlo seguro sino para obtener algún
rendimiento y para que el banco pueda
ofrecerles algún rendimiento les
prestará el dinero a los prestatarios y
les cobrará un interés y para que
podamos apreciar esto de la manera en
que hemos visto los mercados
anteriormente voy a dibujar dos ejes y
para cualquier mercado que hemos visto
antes el eje horizontal es la cantidad y
aquí estamos hablando de la cantidad de
fondos prestables cantidad de fondos
prestables y en el eje vertical
generalmente pensamos en el precio para
el bien o servicio
hablamos de fondos prestables el precio
es la tasa de interés y si queremos
saber el precio real estaremos hablando
de tasa de interés real tasa de interés
real entonces vamos a pensar en estos
escenarios vamos a pensar en los
ahorradores que en realidad son los
oferentes en el mercado de fondos
prestables cuando las tasas de interés
real son bajas ellos en realidad no
quieren proveer una gran cantidad no
tienen suficiente motivación para
ofrecer sus ahorros en esa situación
pero si las tasas de interés real son
altas ellos probablemente dirán me
siento con ganas de ahorrar voy a dejar
mis fondos disponibles para que se los
presten a otras personas porque puedo
obtener un gran rendimiento de esta tasa
de interés especialmente si es una tasa
de interés real de modo que podemos
verlo como algo así
a esto le podemos llamar oferta de
fondos prestables o fp y se pueden
imaginar cómo se verá la curva de
demanda de fondos prestables cuando las
tasas de interés real son altas la gente
dirá oye no hay muchas oportunidades de
negocio que puedan justificar un
préstamo con tasas de interés tan altas
así que no habrá mucha demanda pero si
las tasas de interés son bajas entonces
la demanda de fondos prestables será más
alta de modo que esta será nuestra
demanda de fondos prestables de fp y
como hemos visto en el pasado vamos a
tener una cantidad y precio de
equilibrio donde el precio en esta
situación es la tasa de interés real y
esto va a pasar donde se intersectan
estas curvas esta es nuestra cantidad de
equilibrio y esta es nuestra tasa de
interés real de equilibrio
ahora pensemos en qué pasaría si alguna
de estas curvas o las dos cambia de
alguna manera vamos a empezar con la
demanda de fondos prestables hay un par
de maneras en que estas curvas pueden
cambiar tal vez de repente la gente vea
nuevas oportunidades de negocio la
minería de esteroides está surgiendo y
la gente quiere pedir prestado para
comprar robots y mandarlos al espacio y
traer platino de alguna mina o alguna
otra cosa que pasaría pausa el vídeo y
piensa en esto bueno con cualquier tasa
de interés real habría una alta demanda
de fondos en esa situación
nuestra demanda de fondos prestables se
movería a la derecha y se vería como
algo así
esta es la demanda de fondos prestables
sub 2 algunas veces podrías ver algo
como prima pero le voy a llamar sub 2 y
se movería a la derecha por las nuevas
oportunidades de negocio otra razón
común por la que la demanda se movería a
la derecha es que el gobierno estuviera
pidiendo prestado mucho más recuerden
que este es un mercado agregado de modo
que cuando el gobierno pide prestado más
dinero para alimentar sus gastos también
tiene que entrar en el mercado de fondos
prestables por lo que un mayor
endeudamiento del gobierno también la
movería a la derecha y si sucediera lo
contrario si la gente pensará que hay
menos oportunidades de negocios o si el
gobierno dejará de tomar préstamos bueno
eso movería las cosas a la izquierda
pero pensemos qué pasaría si erre que es
la tasa de interés de equilibrio actual
cierre se queda donde está entonces va a
haber una escasez de fondos prestables
donde los proveedores van a estar
dispuestos a ofrecer esta cantidad
mientras los prestatarios van a querer
esta cantidad de aquí a esta tasa de
interés real
y lo que vamos a ver es que tendremos un
nuevo punto de equilibrio la tasa de
interés real va a aumentar y va a llegar
a este punto que podemos llamar nuestra
nueva tasa de interés real de equilibrio
r
1 y nuestra cantidad va a aumentar
también a este punto q 1 para convencer
a más ahorradores de que su dinero esté
disponible para prestarlo las tasas de
interés tendrán que aumentar y
llegaremos a este punto que está aquí
del mismo modo podemos tener cambios en
la oferta de fondos prestables digamos
que por ejemplo la cantidad de ahorros
cambia por alguna razón hay una gran
campaña de mercadotecnia del gobierno o
en la educación o en las escuelas que
dice que tenemos que ahorrar más para
los días difíciles o que tenemos que
ahorrar para el retiro bueno entonces si
todos ahorran más a cualquier tasa de
interés realidad entonces la curva de
oferta de fondos prestables podría
moverse a la derecha y si pasara lo
opuesto
entonces la curva se movería hacia la
izquierda
esta es la oferta de fondos prestables 2
o fp 2 y luego que pasaría bueno si
estamos en este punto que tenemos aquí y
de repente estamos en una situación en
la que hay un excedente de fondos
prestables a esta tasa de interés las
personas estarán dispuestas a ofrecer
más fondos prestables de los que la
gente está demandando entonces el precio
de los fondos prestables que es la tasa
de interés real bajará a este nuevo
punto de equilibrio y aquí a esto lo
podríamos llamar r sub 2 que sería
nuestra nueva tasa de interés real de
equilibrio y esta sería nuestra nueva
cantidad de equilibrio aquí lo vamos a
dejar lo más importante es que los
fondos prestables operando en el mercado
de la manera en que lo haría casi
cualquier cosa con la diferencia de que
el precio no es sólo una cantidad de
pesos sino que es una tasa de interés y
cómo queremos descontar la inflación es
una tasa de interés real hasta el
próximo vídeo